hey everybody welcome back to my channel
the youtube community is mourning the
loss of nicole thea
the social media star who was eight
months pregnant and expecting a baby boy
has died at the age of 24 on saturday
her unborn son who she planned to name
reign
tragically passed away as well nicole's
family confirmed the heartbreaking news
on our instagram writing
as a family we ask that you give us
privacy because our hearts are
truly broken and we are struggling to
cope with what has happened
according to the daily mail her family
believes she died due to a massive heart
attack
they said she had it in her house when
she started to feel
chest and back pains she was a dancer
and we don't think she had
any underlining health problems however
they won't know for sure
until they receive the post-mortem
[Music]
nicole a london-based youtube
personality was a dancer and accessories
designer
but she was best known for posting
videos documenting her pregnancy
today i just thought let me just quickly
film the bts of my
second spontaneous what is called
pregnancy shoe
her latest video being her maternity
shoe she did with her friends
spikes to my lovely team peace
nicole who has more than 240 000
followers
on instagram announced her pregnancy in
april
writing god gave us the biggest blessing
yet
i'm finally creating a beautiful little
human inside of me
we are already obsessed with you our
little miracle baby
thank you for choosing us to be your
parents and best friends
i just can't wait to see leo man i'm
going to be busy
holding the baby's cheek doing his hair
like this
nicole's boyfriend shared his excitement
about becoming a dad
writing i can't wait to be taking my son
to the parks and playground
he's done so much for me like without
him i don't know how i would get through
this
even with nicole's tragic death fans
will be able to see new
content from the vlogger she had
pre-scheduled youtube videos to upload
to her channel
and with her boyfriend's blessing he
made the decision to allow them to be
aired
hey guys we love you guys so much you
know the love you to show it is
meant to steal especially only